[Music]
Rory Stewart now it used to be quite
easy to introduce you I would have said
Conservative MP I can still say former
Minister we can say you did try briefly
to become Prime Minister but what are
you now I have literally no idea what I
am I mean I was as Emma says I was until
recently a leadership candidate with a
nice group of conservative members of
parliament who were voting for me and
supporting me to be the leader of the
Conservative Party and I thought well
maybe I won't won't be the leader and
then Boris was become Prime Minister so
then I thought ok not gonna be the
leader and now Boris is Prime Minister
I'm not gonna be in the cabinet anymore
so I resigned from the cabinet there's a
very good sack yet before he could sack
me yep exactly
and then I have now discovered I'm not
an MP anymore an 18 out of the 21 of us
who voted against No Deal brexit were
people who supported me for the
leadership campaign so it's like a sort
of purge of the Mensheviks and the in
the Russian Revolution
we've all been kind of thrown out and
now I seem to be somebody in a in a sort
of her in what looks like an enormous
yellow fire risk in the middle of
Hampstead well you've got some military
experience so we're all safe I'm sure
and on a serious note I asked for some
questions on social media this morning
for you got some brilliant ones so I'll
go to those in just a minute but have
you been invited to rejoin the party
that you love and have served because
apparently a few deals are starting to
go down and I wonder if you've been
approached by the chief work by Boris
Johnson's office so there are lots of
rumors about this and we got a letter
from the chief whip but it wasn't an
awfully friendly letter the answer to be
honest is that it would be very very
difficult for most of us now to rejoin
the party because if you think about it
imagine your Kem Clark he's the father
of the house he's been in the House of
Commons since well since I I guess
the time I was born and he has been in
Edward Heath's government and Margaret
Thatcher's government and John Major's
government in David Cameron's government
he's been home secretary Chancellor of
the Exchequer Lord Chancellor he's voted
against the government I think once in
his entire life and has just found
himself thrown out of the Conservative
Party so what exactly would be the route
back and this is what I think the
Conservative Party hasn't really thought
through to imagine that they can somehow
now say okay we'll give you the whip
back on the condition you do what right
because from our point of view it's a
bit like we've been kicked out of the
marital home were sitting in the garden
shed at the bottom of the garden and
there are different strategies from
getting back a 1-1 strategy seems to be
my friend Philip Hammond strategy which
is that you sit in the garden shed and
you you sue the person in the house to
let you back in again right the other
strategy which seems to be the strategy
of sound G mer which is that you walk
out of that garden shed and you move her
next door with someone else right that's
the Lib Dem strategy are you thinking of
joining the live dance I'm not thinking
I don't like that strategy I never like
that stress she um a third strategy I
suppose is to sit in the garden shed and
try to pretend the garden shed is the
house that's kind of the strategy that
I'm that I'm pursuing at the moment but
but the one strategy that doesn't make
sense is for the person in the house to
say you can come back in provided you
publicly humiliate yourself and agree to
lock yourself in the bathroom for the
next 20 years
are you upset though about it on a
personal level as someone who has stood
for the Conservatives how does it
actually make you feel you're obviously
able to paint these pictures of how
there are strategies but when you had
the wit withdrawn how did that feel to
be so it feels very strange because I I
went in to see Boris just before he
became leader to say look I'm going to
resign you must understand that I can't
be in your cabinet because I am against
the No Deal brexit but I thought the
understanding that I had with him was
the normal understanding which is that
you can't be in the government if you
oppose the main part of government
policy but I still believe very strongly
that Parliament could be independent
from government that there wasn't much
point having a parliament if they 100
percent always do what the Prime
Minister says you might as well get rid
of Parliament entirely that it's a
fundamental principle of our
Constitution that members of parliament
are able occasionally to vote against
government so it was astonishing to me
to discover that really when I thought
we'd agreed that what I was giving up is
my role as sexual state for
international development that what I
was really doing is giving up being a
member of parliament at all and I also
think that it's bizarre that our
Constitution even allows him to do this
you couldn't do this in the United
States the president Trump would not be
able to deselect you as the Republican
candidate for Tennessee that would not
be within his power right that would be
something that would rest with the local
parties so there is a you know there are
many constitutionalists who's coming out
now but on the subject that I was asking
in terms of my personal emotional
reaction yeah it's completely
bewildering I mean you know this analogy
of sitting in the garden shed it's
correct I mean I am going yes I feel
it's an abuse of power but I think also
personally although there are many times
when I feel cheerful and many times when
I feel okay I'm gonna stand up for a
different type of politics obviously at
some level I'm going through the
emotional experience to somebody who's
just lost their job or has just been
kicked out of the house and that does
have an effect on your self-confidence
have an effect what you're doing and it
raises questions all these people you've
been working with for nine and a half
years you know local councillors in my
constituency who I've been with through
difficult family troubles who I've
campaigned with now turning against me
members of parliament who were my
friends
now appearing on television saying that
they think it was the right thing that I
get fired so it is it's a it's a tricky
personal time and one of the challenges
is that were sitting in that garden
shedders we're not necessarily
psychologically in exactly the right
position to make the decision on what we
do next and that the decision to jump
next door or go back into there
or sulk in the shed is being taken at a
time of where psychologically we may not
be calm enough to see clearly one of the
things that we know about our new prime
minister yet to be elected by the people
is that he doesn't like being disliked
they're actually one of his great
weaknesses which is a weakness in a
leader regardless of your view of the
leader is that he really struggles
personally with the fact that he is now
a Marmite divisive figure since backing
brexit to leave on that side because he
was a very popular figure nationally
when he was on things like have I got
news view when he was London Maire when
he was a journalist he may not have
liked some men either but he certainly
had that feeling about himself and these
are people who've written about working
with him say this I ask you then do you
think it was Boris Johnson who made that
decision to purge his party of you guys
who he himself out it against for
instance threes and Mays deal twice out
of three times he went with her once at
the end but he didn't lose the wit
Theresa May didn't do that to people
that cabinet that you sat in and on with
Boris Johnson for some time or do you
think it's the work of an even more
unelected official Dominic Cummings
the mastermind of the leave EU campaign
the official campaign who is it is it
Boris Johnson that's the puppet master
or is it is it Dominic doing this so I
think it's very important to understand
that in the end the buck stops with the
person in charge now it may be the case
that this is a strategy driven by
Dominic but the premise that appointed
Dominic the premises supports Dominic
and the premises signed off on the
strategy and the this is something that
often happens in regimes Annie Archie
used to happen traditionally with
medieval English kings the story was
always oh that the person at the top is
fine it's their advisers that's the
problem if only the King knew the
terrible things that their favorites and
advisers were doing and people actually
did this over with Nixon and Watergate
it was an enormous focus on their chiefs
of staff and the people under them and I
I think it's
I think the sort of simple view which is
that you need to pin responsibility on
the elected person at the top is the
correct view and that although it's
tempting to imagine there's some sort of
secret Svengali who does the whole thing
you have to acknowledge that the person
at the top has empowered that person
given that person the parent must bear
moral responsibility for what that
person does if the courts find Boris
Johnson guilty essentially of misleading
her majesty over the probation of
Parliament next week is Boris Johnson's
position as prime minister of this
country untenable do you think his
position is untenable I think the risk
though is that we get into a form of
trumpian politics in other words almost
certainly were the courts to find
against the prime minister he would like
Donald Trump just try to shrug it off
and say I don't care about the court so
I've got the people on my side and we
were getting a sense that already with
his approach to progression his approach
to purging people his statements about
the fact that despite the fact that
Parliament has voted for an extension
he's not going to go to Brussels and
request that extension so what will
happen is not that his position becomes
untenable but that British politics will
become increasingly divisive and
polarized because he will have doubled
down on a tradition which I am also
responsible for so I understand this
cuts both ways that does I'm obviously
criticizing Boris for being
unconstitutional but remember I also
participate in a vote I voted against No
Deal brexit and that vote was made
possible by the speaker breaking
constitutional convention by allowing
asked to introduce a positive motion on
a particular type of special order of
the house so that there is a bigger
problem happening in British politics
which is when it suits us far too many
of us are trying to break the rules to
suit our own position let me be
provocative to a crowd that is is
overwhelmingly a remain crowd how did
you know about do they smell a certain
way please please put up your hand if
you voted remain it was a good guess
okay so it's always good to check a lot
of presumption in politics isn't always
good absolutely we have to we have to
have some intuitions as politicians so
we can't really operate at all but the I
mean with you know if you look at
people's attitude towards the second
referendum you can feel the same thing
which is that for many of us we are
beginning to get into a mindset that the
end justifies the means that we are
becoming increasingly determined to
ignore process and outcomes we don't
like in order to get to what we think is
right and so I think if we're going to
challenge what Boris is doing which is
what I want to do we also have to be
quite disciplined with ourselves and
people like me need to be more careful
about how I approach the constitutional
process as well as attacking him on the
other direction I think it's a very
interesting point to make but I've
particularly asked that question about
Boris Johnson's position becoming
untenable not just because it came up on
social media it was one of the questions
that came in but but also because people
like Sabine Campbell former leader of
the Lib Dems a Scottish QC a former
Scottish QC has actually said he has to
resign next week because you can't lie
to the Queen about your real reasons for
suspending Parliament not least when
your defense secretary has been
overheard saying at an event well the
real reason we did it was because we
need some space and a lack of scrutiny
on brexit I'm badly paraphrasing Ben
Wallace but that he's out there in the
public domain if nothing else so I just
wanted to understand why do you think
somebody like that who no longer really
does have skin in the political game
would say that and he wasn't saying it
in a mischievous way he's saying in a
very serious so I think Emma that in the
past Prime Minister's almost certainly
would have resigned so but but we're
getting into the this is why I'm drawing
the analogy with Trump yes
you basically if you were the editor of
the New York Times you would have felt
for the last two-and-a-half years you
had produced the story every week that
would inevitably lead to the resignation
of the president and doesn't so Ming is
correct I think in the past many of
these things would lead to resignation
but I also think that my reading of the
strategy that Boris is pursuing is such
that he's very very unlikely to respond
to a court case by resigning because he
probably feels that a chunk of the
country I don't know how much chunk of
the country but a chunk of the country
will support him because the chunk of
the country will feel here is this
out-of-touch group of people sitting on
the top of a pyramid I know who they are
they're politicians that journalists
they're judges and they're trying to
undermine the will of the people and if
he aligns himself with people against
them and portrays the judges as being
part of this out-of-touch conspiracy he
can he can ride it through Parliament
versus the people establishment versus
the people's trust and and and he is the
sort of I think for many of his own as
he's a sort of hang grenade which is
being thrown at that group and like a
true politician you didn't quite answer
one part of my question do you think he
should so not do you think he will do
you think there's arguments either side
but do you personally think the
honorable thing to do next week would be
to resign in what you know about law
politics and constitution well I think I
mean in a sense he's too deep in now
I mean he's steeped too deep in this I
mean you where I in that position I hope
I wouldn't have been in that position in
the first place I mean I think the
promise that all these moves are part of
a total strategy which I've tried to
call out from the leadership campaign
even though the problem of the thing
starts with the fundamental dishonesty
the fundamental dishonesty was we're
gonna leave by the 31st of October right
he was never going to be able to leave
by the 31st of October that was obvious
I think how could he possibly I mean as
I kept saying to leadership campaign you
can't get a new deal out of Brussels and
you can't get a no deal through
Parliament so how can you leave by the
31st
that word now I would if he got a new
deal out of Brussels took it through and
left by the 31st of October would be the
first person to apologize I'd go down on
bended knees in front of him and say
you're actually your app see right I'm
completely wrong so if he pulls that off
pulls off this miracle of getting a new
deal out of Brussels and getting that
new deal through Parliament by the 31st
of October I'm gonna be the first to say
oh it's I mean II that I'm totally wrong
that it's completely the end of my
political project however I suspect come
the 31st of October that will not be the
case he will not get a radically new
deal out of Brussels and he won't be
able to get it through Parliament so and
I suppose I've been certain enough of
this for months now to think that saying
that you're going to leave on the 31st
of October do-or-die is somewhere
between a fairy story and an untruth end
of your political project we resign
fully from politics hmm if he gets the
deal through by the end of 31st of
October I think I'm happy to say I
wouldn't run again as a member of
parliament yeah that is what we call a
news line in my line of work if they're
only journalists they're very
interesting very interesting indeed we
shall see one of my favorite things
about asking for questions which I love
doing and especially at my main job is
on radio 5 live every morning and when
I'm interviewing a politician and Rory's
been on a couple of times some of the
best questions come in on the text
console as you're doing it and it's
always you know sue who's listening at
home while doing a bit of cooking or
Barbies on the road whatever is going on
and they just suddenly say it exactly
how it is and this question came in Rory
from a woman called Janet Rory Stewart I
enjoy it she said she enjoyed you in the
leadership contest as many did obviously
in a number vote why haven't you started
another Parliament across the road like
you said you would if prorogation had
taken place okay so that was it - no
okay so the answer to Janet is that I
said
that we'd certain other Parliament
across the road if he's suspended
Parliament in order to prevent us
blocking a No Deal brexit but what we
did and this is why I've actually been
kicked out of the Conservative Party and
left the government is that through the
votes in July we forced him to bring
Parliament back in September and we were
able to use that opportunity in
September to vote to block a No Deal
brexit so we've achieved our objectives
so what would this Parliament do during
those five weeks not clear to me so and
as a result of that if I were to go
across the road and try to hold another
parliament and nobody would turn up
because our objective has been achieved
which is to block an ad or exit I mean
some people may say oh no there were
some politicians who've been trying to
go in and sort of sit there and take
selfies but I take the points I do take
that point I think that's a it's a fair
distinction on on what you said was the
reason for it if you had one that
leadership contest
what would everything look like now
where would we be
I'd probably riots in the streets though
I know in in the dream optimistic
scenario of of winning the leadership I
would hope that what I would have done
is decisively moved the Conservative
Party to become a party of the Center
ground of the radical Center I wanted
very much to find a compromise I was
very excited by the idea of a citizen's
assembly which is getting a group of
people about the number of people in
this tent but selected randomly
scientifically across the country
together to sit and spend three weeks in
public talking through the details of
Brixton and working their way towards
upon price I wanted to get two million
houses built and built quickly within a
five year period I wanted to address out
out social care in a cross-party way I
mean it seems to me that is one of the
real real miseries is that the NHS was a
great achievement but for 70 years we've
thought about how to deal with people
who are ill but we've not come up with a
solution to the frail elderly green
papers white papers but nobody's been
prepared to work cross-party on this
so this I think would have been the
things that I hope that you would have
felt and I'd hope the process would have
been a process of healing of trying to
bring the country together towards the
center ground and that small issue
brexit what would be happening with that
right now so we'd be going through the
citizens assembly and we would have been
working our way to what I believe would
have been an outcome of a compromise in
other words at the time to get the ideas
from the citizens assembly to get to
Brussels to get something back to
Parliament or do you think we would have
had to extend it a little oh we would
have had to accept it yeah we would have
had it said I never had this 31st
October deadline in my head um have you
read David Cameron's book yet no you in
it I don't know I haven't looked at it
well that's what your politicians do in
each other rights but you go straight to
the index it's it's true it's true panic
paddy ashdown once gave me a copy of his
book and I couldn't there was no
dedication in it and then I flipped to
thee to the s and the index and he'd
written above it I knew you'd live you'd
look here for love Hattie
I've written a book about periods and if
you want to talk about periods politics
and power I'll be here at 3 o'clock I
suspect the crowd may be small it may
not be and you're not in it I just
thought I'd clarify that but I did get
asked would Rory happily sit on the tube
and read a book about periods
I think you would I definitely do he's
got to say that yes right um I asked
about David Cameron's memoirs because
it's very interesting what he's been
saying about the Queen Her Majesty's in
the news a lot at the moment due to
former Etonians and not listening you in
that actually David Cameron and I'm
Boris Johnson in terms of whether Boris
was misled whether David has misspoken
and it was David Cameron right to ask
for the Queen even just to raise an
eyebrow in the run-up to that Scottish
referendum but he was wrong
and he was a thousand times wrong if he
did that to then say that he'd done
you're not meant to find that bit out
are you in politics of internalized
totally insane I mean if he actually had
had that conversation of the Queen and
the Queen had been prepared to do that
it is the most astonishing betrayal of
that conversation to put that down
what's wrong with David Cameron and when
it comes to there is a there's a next
bit right but when it comes to
discretion over the monarch he's not got
it has he where he once said she heard
down the phone to me which made our
monarchs sound sexual um I think he
likes inside a gossip he thinks that one
of the charming ways of dealing with a
crowd is is to sort of let you into the
secret of his glamorous life so he often
in speeches will have a little anecdote
about you know this moment he share but
angler Merkel or this funny thing that
he he did with Berlusconi I mean he wow
that would be a good one yeah what did
he do with bonus game well he his great
his great gag was that the one thing
that he he learnt in politics and he'd
say this again and again in meetings is
if Berlusconi invites you to a party
never go if the Queen invites you to a
party always go but this this is party
he's not gonna be invited so anymore by
the Queen but you're right but it but
but I think this is part of the collapse
of seriousness and politics you you
don't actually want your leaders trying
to take you into cozy little moments
with Angela Merkel or the Queen right
you there has to be discretion and
seriousness of the basis what you
actually want us talking about if
possible is how to bring this country
together and make it a better place not
you know bringing you along with me and
my glamorous little life so David
Cameron's contributed to a lack of
seriousness in politics I think our
entire political system including David
Cameron has got into a deeply deeply um
serious space I think the if you wanted
a way of really criticizing Britain you
would say we are in danger of not being
a serious country anymore the policy
conversations are not serious are
approach to brexit has not been serious
our approach to our Constitution is not
serious our approach to foreign policy
is not serious this is a serious country
full of some very serious smart people
and we are so much less than the sum of
our parts we are not being who we should
be and that's about leadership but it's
also about a public that enables leaders
to behave in a non serious fashion in a
moment I'm going to hand you over to
this crowd
not literally for some questions I do
have some non serious questions which
now sort of feels wrong after what you
just said they are from a couple of
other people online who wanted to know
that they one of one of the women who
got in touch had read your favorite
books in this in this week in the Week
magazine excuse me at Middlemarch is in
there I believe she she was a bit
worried that you don't have enough of a
laugh in your life because of your very
serious choices but what makes you laugh
Rory Stewart that's a really good
question um fleabag fleabag makes me
laugh good choice
alright and another one who would play
you in a film I have the answers I've
been dreaming of it since I was very
young I am gonna be played by Danny
DeVito you may have to lose a little
weight
just a little could we please have some
of your wonderful questions straight up
brilliant the banality of both of the
major parties over this brexit issue
shows a moral bankruptcy that I think
both of them are going to have a hard
time recovering from what's your vision
of the political system in say you know
assuming we can get past this in 10
years time do you see it as an ever
increasing polarization between these
two rabid tribes or do you see some new
forms emerging
okay it's a really good question so I
think that there is a very strong logic
towards polarization
so essentially British public opinion
which used to be a sort of bell jar with
all the votes in the middle has now
become a u-shape with all the votes on
the extremes and nobody left in the
center at least so it's so it feels
right but we have to I think advocate
for the center ground I mean my whole
project now is to say these parties are
finished ultimately that way of
approaching politics cannot be sustained
that there has to be a complete
reshaping of our political life and that
it must be possible to make the
arguments for the center ground but to
make those arguments we need to be
prepared to use things like this in
other words we need to be trumpian anti
Trump's we need to learn how to make
quite populist sounding arguments for
non populist causes you need to resist
the temptation to become sort of boring
technocrats I mean that's the danger of
my saying we need to be serious
find a lively engaged way of listening
and engaging and I think that the word
that was most powerful in my campaign
probably had the real energy but it's
very difficult to learn as a politician
as the word love because I think that's
a word which is very very radical full
of courage full of possibility but is in
the end about empathy and bringing
people together rather than dividing
[Applause]
thanks very much just a very quick one
if you if you believe the centre ground
of politics is where people really
should be why wouldn't you join the
Liberal Democrats they're really setting
themselves up as being against
authoritarianism so against extremism
and in favor of liberal values so I
think the thing that shocked me most
about the Lib Dems and the reason that I
wouldn't join them is this announcement
that they're going to revoke without a
second referendum I think that is insane
I think for a program that began for
bricks
voters as here as these people at the
top of the pyramid completely out of
touch the elite just ignore us they're
not interested in our views to then say
we're gonna just remain and we're not
even going to ask you again we're gonna
completely ignore the result of the
references you don't know what's good if
you I think it's totally playing into
that rhetoric mining is deeply deeply
dangerous if you're gonna go for remain
you've got to have a second referendum
and I think actually for a party that
claims to be anti-authoritarian that is
a very authoritarian move Rory why no
mention of Northern Ireland and the
border there okay let me let me finish
on this because that's a very very good
challenge and a very good thing to end
on in talking about why Britain is not a
serious country one of the biggest
elements of that is how little we talk
about Ireland and Nolan is part of our
country and yet often if you read
British media or hear politicians over
the last five years they talk about it
as though it's located somewhere near
Sarajevo right it's not really part of
our political discourse and of course
the fundamental problem with brexit from
the beginning was the issue of Ireland
and yet the remain campaign almost never
talked about Ireland go to Derry
Londonderry at the moment and you are
aware of the fact that the peace there
is very recent and very fragile those
apprentice day marches are things that
still have to be taken through with the
most extraordinary care you will see
peace walls still up you will see this a
Protestant community in living in the
middle of Derry Londonderry that is
quite literally surrounded by 15-foot
walls with Parachute Regiment flags that
you go over those walls and you'll see
big big images of Che Guevara this Good
Friday Agreement was in the end
facilitated by the removal of that
border it allowed people to live in
Northern Ireland and feel Irish or live
in Northern Ireland and feel British
without having to confront the question
of which they were and the economy of
Northern Ireland is deeply integrated
into the Republic 85% of the sheep from
Enniskillen go across the border to
abattoirs in the Republic it's a single
island health economy so amongst the
many many reasons
be very worried about a new deal Brett
said Ireland and indeed I think for me
as a Scot the consequences for Scotland
and the United Kingdom are some of the
deepest reasons why I think an OD or
brexit would be deeply damaging deeply
unnecessary and something we would
regret for years to come
my guess we'll do it in his pants for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you